now for the sake of time I kicked off
the conversion of our schema earlier by
creating a new workspace in database
migration service let's dive into it now
some code was automatically converted by
DMS the green check marks and some still
need our attention let's take a closer
look at one of these instances now this
is an example where duet AI understands
the semantics of an oracle specific
function Cate and recommends a change
for alloy DB postgress to local
timestamp now we need system clock
though so we changed it manually to use
clock
timestamp a large application might have
thousands of similar statements which
would require manual conversion but look
at the sophistication that we have
achieved after just one manual fix du AI
is able to generalize the solution and
apply it across similar instances what
used to take months to migrate manually
is now radically easier with du AI